hello and welcome i'm james murphy have
you ever added two floating point
numbers like point one and point two
and gotten something slightly off
well in this video we'll find out why by
looking at how floating point numbers
are represented
thanks to this video's sponsor anvil a
browser-based
full stack development platform allowing
you to make web apps with nothing but
python
more about anvil at the end of the video
i'm using python
but even if you're using a different
language like c or c plus plus
you probably got the exact same answer
that's because
most programming languages follow the
same standard for representing floating
point numbers
most likely your language uses 32 or
64-bit floats
python uses 64-bit i'll use the struct
library to coax python into showing me
the bits underneath the float
now we can see the actual bits that make
up the numbers point one
point two point three and the sum of
point one and point two
i've put spaces in the numbers here so
that you can see the different parts of
the representation of a floating point
number
the first bit is a sign bit zero for
positive one for negative
the second and third chunks are an
exponent and fraction
like in scientific notation most of the
time
here's what the number represents we
choose the scale of our number by
picking the correct
exponent and then we get the right
digits
by putting everything else into the
fraction where here
one dot fraction is a number between 1
and 2
which is one point and then all of these
bits interpreted in binary
you can represent the numbers 0 all the
way up to 2047
in this exponent we subtract 1023 from
the exponent e
in order to allow ourselves to be able
to represent both really big numbers
but also really small numbers you can
see that 0.1 and 0.2 have the same
fractional part
which makes sense because 0.2 is just 2
times 0.1
so really i just need to increase the
exponent by 1. we also notice
that 0.1 and 0.2 are repeated decimals
because 10 is not a power of 2.
but we only have 64 bits to work with 52
in this group
so that means the repeated decimal got
rounded or cut off at some point
that explains why point one plus point
two is not point three
rounding error here's what one and
negative one look like
note that because there's a one dot at
the beginning of the fractional
part that's implicit we don't need to
put that one in
that's why the representation for one is
just all zeros in the fractional part
the exponent is 1023 to offset the bias
and the sign bit is zero for positive
negative one is the same with a flipped
sign bit
and here's what zero and negative zero
look like
that's right negative zero any real
number that has a floating point
representation
has only one except for zero that's the
only exception
the representation of zero is all zeros
and the representation
of negative zero just has a one in the
sign bit
you can see that they compare equal to
each other but they're definitely not
the same
object this is different say from
integer 0 and negative 0
which are exactly the same object you
can also represent plus or minus
infinity as a float
infinities are an exception to the
formula from before you just set the
exponent to all ones
and the fraction to all zeros and then
set the sign bit accordingly
notice that if you take a big number and
multiply it by something you might get
infinity you can also represent nands or
not a number in python using an exponent
of all ones and anything that's not all
zeros for the fraction
you can make a nand directly or do
something like multiply
infinity times zero nands are also one
of the only kinds of objects that don't
compare equal to themselves
aside from nan's and infinities there's
one more exception to the rule for the
formula for a floating point number
basically when the exponent gets down to
zero you drop the implicit
one at the beginning of the fraction
this allows you to get a few more powers
of two closer to zero
but if you try to go too far you will
just hit zero
so what should you do if you want to
compare floats for equality
well don't use equals equals just look
at the absolute value of their
difference
and then check to see if it's really
small basically you're saying
if the difference is smaller than this
then i'm just calling them equal
of course if you're not okay with any
error and you really need an exact
representation
then you might prefer something like the
decimal library
the decimal library is built into python
and stores your numbers
as a string so they can be as long as
they need to be to get the exact
precision that you desire
of course if you're trying to represent
an irrational number like square root of
2
you're out of luck but if you're only
dealing with rational numbers and you
really need exactness like if you're
dealing with money
then you should definitely use the
decimal library storing decimals as a
string may take a little bit more memory
but
obviously it's worth it if you need the
exact precision
hey everyone thanks for watching slap
that like button an odd number of times
and if you want to hear about the video
sponsor anvil stick around
anvil has everything you need to develop
and deploy a web app written completely
in python
including the front end so no javascript
or html required
and it's free to try create your user
interface by dragging and dropping
components
anvil's web-based ide allows you to
develop in your browser
no need to install anything you can use
anvil's built-in database and let anvil
handle the tricky parts like user
authentication
when you're ready deploy your app to the
cloud with a single click
check out the link in the description to
get started with anvil today